welcome to this video this is a new
video in the series covering my games
from the open tournament I recently
played on the island of Majorca let's
look at this game if you have seen the
first three videos you'll know that I
had an excellent start in this
tournament with three wins in a row so
three out of three possible points
beating the Grandmaster and the third
round yeah it was a bit of a lucky win
this third round win against them twine
is from Lithuania but still a win is a
win so I was pretty much a shirt to get
a strong opponent in round four and I
got one yet another Grandmaster this was
a game with white against you risu load
off lead chenko solid awfully [ __ ] a
very long name he's rated 2574 close to
the 2600 mark he also was above that
mark him for a while but he's usually is
hovering between two 515 and to 620
somewhere around this oh yeah of course
I did some preparation for the game but
it turned out to be not too easy
he's playing more than one opening not a
very predictable player so um I just
decided to to play a d4 and see what
happens yeah we got this set up the so
called triangle setup this is something
that he had played before but I
mentioned as mentioned I couldn't be
sure that I get exactly this opening
yeah I decided to play Queen c2 and
that's my usual move here covering the
c4 pawn and keep some flexibility for
for the other pieces what I'd like to do
is he played nine f6 to play Bishop g5
and then III getting the bishop out of
the pawn chain and get a pneumonia setup
that's not so easy in fact
if you look at this position if you want
to do that you have problems with the c4
pawn if you don't play Queen c2 after
this for example Blacky can play this
this opening the so-called notable
variation leads to a very sharp play
both black very often just keeping in
the pawn so on if you want to keep the
c4 pawn and get your Bishop out you
pretty much have to play green c2
yeah my my line is mentioned I have some
experience with that however he managed
to play in a sub variation that I
absolutely did not know age six bishop
age four yet here the most common move
by far is the capture on c4 after which
why--just recaptures and yeah we go from
there
white normally tries to develop with III
92 or 93 very often the Queen gets a
kick with b5 this is some line that they
have played a number of times but he
sorry played something entirely
different
he played Queen a5 check and I am clean
I knew the general idea of course for
example there is there is this check but
he played the screen a5 move immediately
and this irritated me a bit I am
absolutely had not looked at this in any
preparation so I needed to yeah - to
play a real game here not relying on
when anything has studied beforehand
yeah I wasn't sure what to do against
the check I mean pretty much Knight d2
Knight c3 and that ft2 is possible and
they all make some sense
however the moves lugnut ft2 seemed a
bit passive to me the problem is of the
general problem is sometimes black here
gets very strong and quick counter play
with Knight e4 Bishop before
utilizing this pin note that there is
always g5g fall so to to to kick there
three nights so if black is doing right
is doing some stupid moves he can easily
be get into trouble I can just put
something on the board that is somewhat
cooperative you know let's say something
like this and now g4 yeah Night Moves 92
and white resigns as Queen d2 Bishop b4
loses the Queen this kind of tricks are
in the position so need to be a quite
alert here already yeah well after a
while I decided to play Knight c3 and
just giving up the pawn on c4 usually I
don't like to do that playing this in
gambit style but in this particular
position I thought it would be worth it
because if you look at this he took
really quickly I am able to take on f6
and damage black's pawn structure this
is a big difference to some other lines
where this pawn is sacrificed here black
really has somewhat wrecked thorn
structure of course he's got the two
bishops very important long-term this
can be a big big factor yeah well I am
had to work this out over the board's
own and I think my my judgement here was
okay I have enough compensation for the
pawn
however it's debatable if the next move
was right I played g3 obviously
preparing to fianchetto with hindsight
maybe e3 is some is to be preferred it
has a big advantage over g3 and this is
that it directly attacks the pawn and
this means that black needs to react to
that and probably needs to play b5 and
here I'm actually assured that he has to
play b5
and in this way also and weaken the
whole queenside structure especially the
light squares run in the game after g3
it's not really necessary for him to
play b5 and maybe therefore III is a bit
yeah it is to be preferred that's
possible I mean my position was
perfectly okay in the game just
afterwards I thought well maybe III
would have been better after all he
played 97 Bishop g2 and Bishop g7 yeah
at the moment it looks strange the
bishop on g7 but after short castles and
this is what we did now castles and
castles this bishop is an important
defender of the King and after a later
f5 this Bishop on g7 is a very strong
piece so this makes lots of sense yeah
in this position here is one of those
cases where you would like to have more
time on your hands
as I mentioned in earlier videos we
played a very quick time control 90
minutes per game and 30 seconds
increment per move so if you just take
two or three longer things of 10 minutes
or something you're already very much
down on the clock yeah here the problem
is what I'd like to do is I'd like to of
course ideally I get the pawn back with
an active position um and this whole
thing is centered around a couple of
moves that I should play in some order
92 a form and III those moves and my
next move the question is in what order
yeah this is not not so easy to to say
because what I want to have the pawn
back or to provoke him to to weaken the
Queen side further maybe in this
position 92 was them wasn't was most
more interesting I played a form and
rather quickly
I looked at this for two minutes around
two minutes and thought well you're not
going to work out now what is the best
move on herself just play one of the
moves the a form makes it more difficult
for him to play em to play b5 and it
also very often can happen that a four a
five wins an important tempo on a night
that might appear on B 6 a 4 has some
points there also was 90 tunes and maybe
this is even more interesting if we look
at this what should black play let's say
it starts with f5 yeah attacking here
III Knight b6 this is this kind of setup
here there are some interesting
possibilities for white one interesting
move for example is to play a3 intending
to play before taking the Queen or even
the direct b3 is a move yeah something
like that would be a very nice
compensation with the bishop and the
Knights having pressure here on the
Queen side on b3 or every sv5 so it's
it's not easy at all but this would have
been interesting just they're not
playing a four immediately and try to
use the different move water this was
not bad yeah but the alternatives were
very much worth considering yeah he went
f5 as I expected you need to activate
this bishop and now III I don't think I
can play without the move I want to make
this night flexible that it can actually
move and maybe pick up the pawn and the
bishop was always attacking d4 so that's
very logical
he played see fire fear this is also
what I expected him trying to attack the
d4 pawn yeah and here it gets it gets
very interesting
um it seems that here I had an
interesting alternative that I did not
really appreciate I played Knight b5
which is okay but there also was the
move
d5 that I didn't really consider but it
is very interesting the move has one
particular virtue it detects the light
squares like this and this can maybe
even intensify it maybe nine h4 it sort
of yeah tries to claim that this queen
is a bit offside I didn't really
consider this this in much detail I just
thought okay he's going to play this and
I didn't really look further I mean it
didn't seem right to me to play d5 and
then take but the truth is if you look
at this takes ya Bishop takes this is
total name it's really really I'm not
good so context and now I have a good
movie form and this I didn't see at all
here white has a very substantial
compensation note that the queen is
really off site and the whole position
in the center will be would be will be
opened up this would have been very
interesting maybe black needs to do
something else after d5 like him just I
don't know play play a little
strengthening move Knight b6 has the
disadvantage of course that the Queen
cannot go back it's really cutting off
the Queen's retreat d5 was very
interesting yeah I played Knight b5 the
idea was to also just get the pawn back
yeah and now he took on T for this are
also expected um and he takes d4 you
know that's better than taking with the
piece the pawn here is isolated okay but
it controls those important square as if
I'm
take with with the night then there is
Knight to e5 for example he can now use
the knight on a central square which is
not possible after the pawn recapture so
the poem the pawn recapture I think is
just the battles Knight b6 keeping the
pawn for the moment and yeah okay I only
have one logical move 95 trying to get
it back yeah and now it gets very
concrete he now played the move a6
desire I didn't really expect to be
honest um I saw exactly what happened in
the game and I thought that black
shouldn't shouldn't allow that it is
playable though the move a6 what I had
actually expected was rook the age now
this is not not a bad move as well it
just yeah put some more pressure here
and my plant reply was Queen c3 looks a
bit weird but I think it's quite good as
it strengthens white center and white
still has compensation here for the pawn
with a 4 a 5 a 6 these kind of ideas
very complicated position and certainly
an alternative for black his approach is
different he just said okay I'll take
all pawns that you offer me and I'm
going to defend this a6 essentially wins
wins upon all of you if you want 2
points 96 of course not going to retreat
here the taking c4 yeah and now we just
took only five yeah grabbing grabbing
the pawn and yeah if you do a quick
count like it's two pawns up now however
now I'm played I played rugby 1 we can
put this on the board how ever it is
quite apparent that white has a very
substantial compensate
for the pawns yeah I have a super
diagonal here the bishop is very strong
have a good night on d6 Lex position is
somewhat loose tonight on b6 for example
and the king um they are doing the drink
during the game I was only thinking okay
am I better here or is it just a
compensation and yeah it is in fact it
seems to be just compensation I don't
think that white has an advantage em
yeah we should look at the next moves
black here now played a very good
defensive move played a 5 it's not a
very attractive looking move but a4 a5
or such a strong threat you need to
address that here we had a very
interesting point I have captured on C
form after just a short thing um I
thought it was very difficult to judge
if you should take on c4 immediately or
if you should play some sort of
preparation for the only preparation
that that really came to my mind is Roxy
Roxy one yeah but I didn't do that
because I thought that maybe f4 would
help like getting rid of one of the
pawns and at the end I will take here
anyway
so I decided to just just take it
immediately I mean it's really a matter
in with this quick time control to at
some point just yeah trust your gut
instinct and play the move that you
think it's right if you see two very
similar moves just one needs to be
played
note that getting back the pawns or one
pawn here is really not helping at all
something like ninety seven for example
is a terrible
that yeah this would have exchanged by
excellent night on d6 for for this pawn
and especially for the bishop on c8 the
bishop one c8 is blacks blacks problem
charge but not doing anything and I
shouldn't yeah take this off for just a
single pawn the same applies for the
capture here yeah something like that
it's this is the same position right
yeah that's even the same position so
taking one of the pawns this is really
out of the question
I just took here and it's okay I mean I
really cannot blame myself the the moves
are okay
take him and of course it took me to
that's the only sensible move you need
to grab the material him and yeah he's
two pawns up yeah rook be one logical I
guess and the Queen went back to f6 and
Queen c7 yeah also I think very obvious
this move entering into blacks camp
yeah and black is very much paralyzed he
cannot he cannot do anything active here
White's compensation is is very apparent
but it's two pawns no two points is
quite something but still I had seen
this position when I am when I initiated
the whole thing with with Knight takes
e4 and I thought okay this should be
enough and it is enough but it gets very
very difficult to play he now played in
the Moose King g7 this is just just
except a move it covers covered the h6
pawn get some off the back rank and yeah
well black detect couldn't do anything
active anyway so it this makes some
sense so what should Y do now here we
come to the point or one point where you
you can look for improvements I think of
course you can look for improvements
before but I think here it is quite
clear that white should have enough
compensation but how exactly do you play
that's not not so clear at the end I
decided to play rook to b5 my idea was I
mean in general it is a good active move
it prevents any 65 stuff and while I
thought maybe just get one pawn back
without any big problems and keep them
the pressure on it's not clear that this
was the best choice there is also the
move rook to b6 which are also
considered which I also considered data
also considered but it was very hard to
determine what move this better really
um one point here of putting it on B
sixes if you look at the following
look e8 that's a very viable defensive
try black tries to get the Queen back to
e7 or rook to e7 trying to get this look
into play after that I have a good move
Bishop f1 and this is an important point
why the look on b6 that makes lots of
sense b5 is a square for the bishop for
example after Queen d7 Queen c3 check
check
it is not easy for black to avoid the
repetition now this is this kind of
repetition
check the move like King h7 after rook B
to d6 can be very very tricky for black
I mean what exactly are you playing next
for example if black tries to yeah try
to activate with E 5 and attending the
bishop move there is amongst others the
idea Bishop b5 let's say root 2 G 8 and
then Bishop to d7 that's probably not
even the best move but I just want to
show the idea it looks weird to exchange
this undeveloped bishop but
the other hand now the rooks can enter
on the seventh rank and all pawns here
are under tech this is a really strong
compensation and yeah I mean here I
really prefer white even in with the
computer only showing I'm sorry for my
voice hmm showing zero zero zero this
seems very very dangerous for black
that's just one one idea but I didn't I
didn't really fully appreciate it and
just mentioned at some point you just
needed to to get with or get on with the
moves that that you thought were right I
played that I played rugby 5 played
rupee 8 and that took the pawn and it's
not a mistake I'm just saying that rugby
6 was maybe better this and now he came
came with e5 yeah and here um it dawned
on me that well maybe there was
something better I mean he got in a 5
still look at this Queen c7 he still
cannot move the pawn and sorry the
bishop without losing the pawn one
problem though is that he gets in eform
this is this I had seen and I thought
okay well I have Bishop f1 with the
possibility Bishop to b5 similar to what
we saw before and well those pawns iam I
mean they're obviously better there than
on e6 here this has helped like because
you can probably develop at some point
but still have a very good control over
f4 and for example or Kansas some end
games here even a pawn down would be
easily drawn a rook and came for example
a bishop then came all those would would
draw relatively simply mixed end games
like Queen and Bishop against Queen and
Bishop are a different matter but the
pure Bishop endgame for example would be
probably a pretty pretty easy draw
because of the double pawn so there are
very substantial chances to have a full
compensation
but it's not as good as with rook b6
problem yeah here he played the moose
Queenie five maybe not the best it's
possible that Queen d7 was was better
but it's really impossible to to play
perfect chess with this quick time
control yeah rook see one that's fairly
logical I want to keep the Queen here
especially keep b7 on that egg yet here
and he played the most yeah the most
interesting the most fighting we played
Queen to be to the Queen trade also was
possible but here I think I really
should have should have enough to to
keep this keep this even the Bishop c4
counter idea against f7 should be a
should be enough believable yeah it
couldn't be too as some more interesting
move anyway yeah I went to Roxy to
attacking the Queen went to a-1 yeah and
here and exactly he exactly in in this
position we we have a very critical
position in the game and in fact I think
what I play next smell only my only
substantial mistake really I mean I made
I made a even bigger mistake at the end
but there I was already in very
substantial trouble I played the move a
five year it seemed seemed very logical
to me this was hanging a five keeps the
pawn and it keeps the whole activity
that white has I had a better move
though and the main problem or what is
what annoys me the most is that I didn't
even consider the move and this is
really really bad and white has a strong
move yeah and this is a queen b8 it's
just strong it detects the bishop I
didn't consider the move at all really I
only saw it after
when the computer pointed it out to me
and this seems to be quite okay for
white the bishop is hanging it needs to
move obviously yeah 227 maybe Queen d7
and now I have still maintained a very
active position this is a position that
we should compare to to the game where
we had the same structure we also had
been a pawn exchanged but I was far more
passive than I am here um it's not so
easy to to thoroughly analyze this but
let's look at some samples if Queen a4
for example he takes it with the Queen
there is rook 82 and here we see a very
important point black really would like
to put the bishop on e6 however this is
not possible a check we should be 5 and
black resigns from me with this fork was
this is cure yeah whatever it detects to
pieces and wins one of them yeah so he
cannot go there so it probably needs to
play move like this and now Queen -
Queen to b6 yeah and here white is just
much more active than than in the game
the whole coordination is a bit
disturbed on the black stuff because of
this Bishop on c6 it really would prefer
very much to be only 6 but as we saw it
was not working due to due to technical
reasons due to concrete variations yeah
the Queen b8 would have regained yeah
are exchanged let's say the B and a pawn
and white would would have retained the
activity
I played a5 and now we see that he can
play Bishop e6 and what we now get is a
much improved version as he has the
bishop on e6 which she didn't get in the
other line this was a coordinates of
course not easy to to see but
the problem was that I didn't really
consider quean a quean be ADA at all I
was just seeing okay eight five looks
sorry I was just seeing that okay a five
looks normal let's play that and it
turned out that I really should have
calculated much more thoroughly and then
spot Queen b8 yeah Bishop e6 and that
played
yeah rook c1 first attacking of the
Queen he does not want to want to draw
yeah
yeah I went to e5 yeah I also could have
tried to to continuously attack the
Queen but he has other squares he can do
here for example um yeah I I went oops
check I went here and rugby to its also
makes lots of sense attacking attacking
here now Queen d5 we after some moves
yeah this is what I was getting at we
get the same structure that I could have
gotten with Queen b8 but just in a in a
much much worse version as here he has
the most Queen e1 and this is what I
didn't really didn't really see how
problematic this already is in the moves
before I had alternatives but they
already are not so attractive anymore
here for example I absolutely should
have exchanged Queens but the problem
was I didn't see how bad luck see
Adrienne is for me I mean Luke see a
rooks 8 is just wrong the IDS Queen D 1
and Rupe c1 his King on g6 is fairly
safe and I absolutely didn't see how
problematic disease well as mentioned I
went look b6 yeah
setting up here this pin and then we we
got this trade and after Queen e1
I was down to a Natasha three minutes or
something four minutes for the rest of
the game with the suit with this
30-second increment yeah and here I
recognized how how bad it is and I
simply simply couldn't find a move I
first discarded rook b8 I calculated
rooks e7 all kinds of moves the problem
is always Bishop c4 and then killed here
on the on the on the back rank yeah and
with the clock er
going going down at the end I thought oh
well looka p8 is working and I
overlooked something I played rugby ATM
which yeah one loses instantly but it
turns out that I don't have any any
defense here anymore what I saw actually
is Queen e3 but the problem is I mean
this is not clear that it is winning
it's obviously much better for black but
it's not clear that is winning for
example after rook trade this is a dead
draw yeah so only with rooks on like em
can succeed probably the problem is
though he does not need to take and I
can play Queen here and get this in also
if you look at this for example this is
a terrible position simply I have no
moves if I go King g2 as III and there's
no defense whatsoever
the position is already lost well so
rook b8 it was based on a miscalculation
but it is already lost he just took it
and played Bishop c4 yeah of course and
seeing that Queen's Queen f1 is deadly
but I had a simple a simple Miss misstep
played Queen b8 a queen g8 and by now I
had recognized my problem I had
initially I thought he must go here and
then I thought okay this will be a will
be a perpetual in fact here winning but
yeah the problem was simply I overlooked
that he can go to age five yeah it's
just as simple as that the bishop now is
is covering f7 and I don't even have a
check and while I can I can give this
despite shaky at reform but I didn't
bother I just resigned here in this
position
I simply overlooked that he can go to
age five yeah so at the end I didn't
play this position precisely enough it
started
exactly here with this move a five so
here absolutely must play Queen b8 I
absolutely must do that after that I
have enough activity probably to to
compensate for the pawn after this he
manages to get the Bishop to e6 and I
absolutely didn't appreciate how
important that is and that I can
actually prevent it with Queen B age my
problem was I didn't really use the the
candidate moves principle he I just
played a5 rather quickly and yeah now it
is pretty clear that the position after
Queen b8 is just much better than this
here it's it's very tricky already to to
keep this to keep this going what I
probably still should have done here is
to exchange Queens this is not much fun
really not but this was the the toughest
defense the at least there are still
some ideas how the game could end in a
draw but it is it is very tough to do in
a practical game for example or one
problem is that if I go a six which I
would like to do I'd like to get rid of
pawns he's got this
look a eight and possibly going quickly
to a one yeah that's really not much fun
to defend I'm pretty sure that I would
have lost this in the long run but
objectively speaking I probably must do
it yeah and here here I'm already busted
I guess Queen d1 and rooks e1 it's just
too much the weakness here of the the
back rank is too much of a problem
yeah I'm still a bit thinking about it
did I really need to lose the game yeah
probably not
I mean I had really a very nice
conversation but Queen b8 is the move
that I needed to play or instead of
getting the pawn back immediately here
or one pawn back this move rook b6 yeah
maybe this was was really a much
stronger yeah so simply well this Bishop
is so strong on this diagonal and I
didn't really think about this type of
maneuver it's um it's very
counterintuitive but it is strong yeah
even getting it to b-52d 727 to invade
on the seventh rank it's very very
strong
but tough to find really tough to find
you know okay I mean I'm not sure I
should be too critical of myself for the
game it wasn't it wasn't terribly bad
but yeah after you have real sacrifice
to ports and nexon and I got some some
pressure going you thought okay maybe it
would have been nice to get more than
lost out of it but on the other hand you
need to appreciate what he did there he
played absolutely precisely the whole
time he grabbed the two pawns I just
said okay show me what what do we have
for the two pawns and I didn't manage
really I I got one back and then I made
this inaccurate nice not playing Queen
b8 and after that he just very
clinically won the game so just a very
good performance by the black player
it's not
it's not really my kind of chess I don't
like to take those pawns and try to try
to defend this precisely but it is it is
a valid style of play of course as we
have witnessed him okay
despite the loss I hope you enjoyed the
game I think it was fairly interesting
nevertheless okay thanks for watching